a huge blowout between a blow-up brother
between President Trump and Democratic
leaders has done nothing to stop the
rising call for impeachment hearings
Democrats say that mr. Trump stormed out
of a meeting with top Democrats at the
White House yesterday three minutes
after it started then he told reporters
he won't work with Democrats until they
stop investigating his administration
sources tell CBS News the president got
mad when House Speaker Nancy Pelosi said
he was engaged in a cover-up Democrats
say they think the walkout and news
conference were pre-planned chief
Washington correspondent major Garrett
is with us
major good morning do you I mean do you
think this clash was part of some larger
strategy well strategy is always a
delicate word to use around Congress and
this president because they are clashing
and they want to clash president Trump
loves fights for a purpose sometimes in
the moment and sometimes later
downstream the pact is he declared
yesterday infrastructure's not going to
happen that means also a budget deal may
not happen emergency flood relief may
not happen lots of things that were
moving along are now stopped how he left
the meeting is much less important than
things have now reached a full gridlock
stage in Washington the great deal maker
is making no deals and the people's
business is being neglected he's accused
of stonewalling on a lot of different
things what do you think the
administration hopes to accomplish by
that well the administration's point of
view is every congressional subpoena is
invalid and until the courts rule
otherwise that's going to be its
position and its posture what House
Democrats look at that is saying if
you're going to tell us everything we're
doing is illegitimate we have to go to
court or impanel an impeachment
committee which has different powers
which by precedent courts have said have
more oversight and can obtain things
that a standard committee can't that's
why you're seeing more pressure among
House Democrats to at least in panel and
impeachment committee so it has more
power to get what Democrats want the
Speaker Pelosi said the bar for
impeachment is overwhelming evidence and
bipartisan support doesn't sound like
we're there yet but is the president
worried when he says I word he doesn't
mean infrastructure no means impeachment
he does and the sense about impeachment
the White House is go for it you're not
going to get it in the Senate I will be
going to be into running area
you would say your ass you're obsessed
with that one thing to remember and
paneling an impeachment committee
doesn't mean you are definitely going to
impeach a president but it does give you
more at more power to obtain evidence
which might lead in that direction
nature quickly a federal judge rejected
the president's request to block
congressional subpoenas for his banking
banking records in your New York State
also move in his state records keep an
eye on this this is moving the
president's wall there is being knocked
down by the federal courts if it is
breached records that have long been
suppressed will be in public view not
necessarily a scandal but the president
hasn't wanted them out you'll find out
why major assets standoff between the
two sides it seems who do you think
blinks first it's not a matter of
blinking these are institutional powers
the courts the legislative branch and
the executive branch they're all have
their own equities and they are sorting
them then Thesz themselves out in a
process it may not move as rapidly as
some in the political sphere may want
but these are moments that are testing
all of our institutions yeah yeah
president likes that he may not like it
in the end and if you've enjoyed this
conversation as I have you can watch
more major Garrett tonight on the CBS
Evening News have you enjoyed it I have
something every time a major encore